我是想让你帮我分析一下，
就是我现在遇到一个情况，
就是两个男生，
我不知道怎么选择，
一个是我前任，
一个是算是现任吧，
我前任的情况是我们本来是朋友，
然后后来在一起做生意，
发展成情侣的一种一种关系，
我一四年的时候毕业，
然后经由亲戚的一个介绍吧，
一个带领，
然后开了一个店，
一直比较稳定，
一年差不多是10多个W，
然后我换了，
换了一个一个地方，
但是生意做的不太好，
然后这个时候呢，
我那个前任他就跟我说，
要不我们一起做大一点，
就开大一点的店，
我带了20个，
然后他带了20个，
但是都是有他的名字来贷款的，
然后到19年一直还算稳定一点，
就是虽然赚的不多，
但是还算稳定，
然后19年到二二年的期间，
也就是碰到一个口罩的一个情况，
所以就是亏的，
包括店里的房租以及人员工资啊，
都是亏的，
等于就是那40个W没怎么还，
这期间其实我们不光是店里的一些经营上面出了问题，
然后我们感情会出了问题的，
他也有一些客户什么的，
其中有两个客户比较特别，
就是他前任，
有一个是他处了两年的前任，
有一个是他当时介绍的一个对象，
但是没处成，
人家就嫌他家里条件差了，
没处成，
他一直都。
就联系，
就是以一种客户的这种名义来店里消费啊，
然后再联系，
有一次他那个前任就当着我的面把他约出去吃饭，
我就觉得受到挑衅，
他吃完饭回来的时候，
我就跟他争吵，
发生了一一次很大的争吵，
也就是那次之后感情不是很好了吧，
他家是兄弟姐妹三个，
他一个姐姐一个弟弟，
她爸爸呢，
是在他十几岁的时候因病去世了，
他姐姐是已经结过婚嫁出去了，
有了孩子，
他弟弟就是小的时候因为好像从树上摔下来，
脑部受到创伤，
智力低下的那种，
就等于就需要照顾，
我和他在一起的时候，
我家人和和我朋友是不同意的，
然后再加上他姐姐一直对我挺有敌意的吧，
那个时候就决定分开了，
后来因为我和他之间还有债务的一个情况，
就是我们贷款的那40万是从他名下贷的，
然后我们分开的时候就协议说我那个每个月还正常还款，
我们分开之前其实是算订过婚的，
就是他给过我家的彩礼，
是一个8万八的一个彩礼，
然后我就跟他说，
我们贷款的这个钱我们一起还，
彩礼的这个钱我会还给你，
就这样子分开了差不多有半年左右的时间，
我认识了我们公司的一个，
就是现任吧，
一个男孩子在一块处的还可以，
但这个。
那时候呢，
我现任就他找回来就是想跟我复合，
他当时就我们决定分手的时候，
我爸妈是不知道的，
但现在知道了，
然后我爸妈就是觉得说还是跟前任在一起，
就现在卡到这个点上，
我不知道是怎么选择，
你先说说这个现任好不好，
就是他条件怎么样啊，
爸妈是干什么的呀，
性格怎么样啊，
对你怎么样啊，
你爸妈之所以不喜欢现任，
想让你跟前任复合，
原因是什么呢？
现任他是独生子，
然后爸妈就是在农村镇上开一个小店，
他的收入也就五六千块钱这样子，
我我觉得跟我是。
还比较符合的，
我几乎没有吵过架，
但是有一点就是他们没有什么上进心，
就觉得上个班就可以了，
我爸妈之所以让你跟前任去复合，
原因是什么呢？
就是说了彩礼，
还有就是他确实嗯，
人品还不错，
那你们彩礼为什么到现在还没退人家呢？
因为我爸妈不愿意退，
你爸妈就因为不想退彩礼，
就让你去嫁给一个前任，
前任负担还这么重，
对吧？
还有一个就智力有点问题的，
需要靠前任养一辈子的弟弟，
你爸妈对我，
我所以说我家里我一四年到一八年的期间，
其实也攒了一些，
长了，
应该是有三四十个是有的吧，
基本上都是花在家里的，
我自己也就就是有一辆车，
当时就买了一辆车，
你觉得你爸爸妈妈是真的为你好吗？
肯定不是为我好，
我我虽然说当时跟前任有一些这种矛盾，
但现在我是能感觉到，
就是我们在谈恋爱期间，
他是对我很好的，
就是我们不是有个贷款，
40万，
其实他的已经还的差不多了，
他现在是还我那部分，
我已经明确拒绝他，
让他不要帮我还，
但是因为在他的名下，
他每个月还是还，
还是往里面打，
就是确实他是想要挽回我的，
对我很不错，
我问你啊，
姐妹啊，
我们抛开所有的条件，
抛开所有的历史，
就是你内心，
你更喜欢谁，
现在。
对，
前任就是主要是愧疚吧，
如果是这样的话，
姐妹啊，
让你的前任去起诉你的爸妈和你要这个，
他有这个88000的彩礼，
因为你和你的爸爸妈妈要承担连带责任，
钱任实际上被你爸妈收了，
那么他们就可以成为被告，
让你的前任去起诉，
要这个88000的这个彩礼，
你喜欢谁就跟谁在一起，
如果现任本人性格没有问题，
收入也比较稳定，
你们俩对吧，
也比较相投，
跟现任生活，
不要为了那88000的彩礼，
不要因为你爸妈不愿意推那88000的彩礼把你一辈子给毁了，
尤其是你有了现任，
有了一个更喜欢的男人之后，
你再回过头去跟那个你不是那么喜欢的男人过日子的话，
对于一个女人来说是极为痛苦的，
你要说没遇到现任，
没遇到一个更喜欢的男人，
你回过头去跟他过日子的话，
或许大家也能凑合过。
一旦你遇到了一个你更喜欢的男人，
你再回过头去跟那个你不那么喜欢的男人过日子的话，
我跟你说啊，
你就肯定过不好。
不要因为你爸妈不想推你八万八的彩礼，
然后去决定你将来嫁给谁，
这是一件很可怕的事情。